hello everyone i'm edward pine and i'm
going to be talking about local access
to random watts and this is joint work
with amartya shankar biswas and ronit
reubenville
the motivating theme of this work is the
idea of big data in computation
with modern algorithms and data sets not
only can we be in the situation where
the input so for instance the graph g
that we want to do some computation on
is too large to store in memory we can
be in the situation where even the
output that we want to use suppose a
maxible independent set in this graph is
also too large to store in memory
so motivated by this dual challenge we
can model problems like this with local
computation algorithms which was a model
introduced by rubenfeld at all
and this model has been applied to all
sorts of problems
um including but not limited to maximal
independent set packing problems uh
constructing low stretch graph spanners
string problems and a huge variety of
other work
so one way to think about the idea of a
local computation algorithm is with the
following schematic
so we have a lca which will always
denote a and we give this lca access to
a read-only random tape which we always
denote r
and we give it probe access to some huge
input
so suppose this huge input is a graph g
and we give it the ability to ask for
the neighbors of vertices for instance
what we want a to do is we want a to
provide implicit access to a huge output
so for instance if we have some graph g
here our huge output could be a maximal
independent set of g
and so we can ask a queries like is
vertex v in the maximal independent set
and a can look at its random tape and it
can look at its huge input and it can do
some computation and then it needs to
answer and so here it says no
and after a answers we're going to wipe
a's memory so it's not allowed to
remember the queries that it has
answered before
and the advantage that that gives us is
we can have multiple copies of a running
around simultaneously so for instance we
have the second copy over here
answering questions like is v prime in
the maximal independent set and this one
says yes and these answers are
guaranteed to be consistent because the
answers that a gives do not depend on
the prior queries nor the query order
and so we have this
nice property
so the prior example was a local
computation algorithm for a single fixed
object like a maximal independent set
evan levy medina and rosen and biswas
rubinfeld and yopanyani instead consider
the idea of local computation algorithms
for huge random objects
so what's going on here is we're going
to allow local access to a random object
drawn from some distribution
the definition of such an algorithm is
very similar to the standard definition
of lcas but here we say a local access
algorithm a is an oracle that allows
query access to some object w drawn from
a distribution over object's d
a is initialized with a read-only shared
random string r and it uses r to select
an object w from this distribution and
then to answer queries about w
and again as in the previous case a has
its memory erased between subsequent
queries
one example we can think of here is
letting d be the set of random walks on
a line graph so these are random plus
minus one steps starting from zero
the query we're going to ask the
algorithm is give us the height of the
walk at time t
so give us the height of the walk at
time five and then it draws a walk from
the distribution of random plus minus
one step walks and then answers
according to that object
and
note here that rather than requiring a
to answer exactly according to this
distribution we're going to say it can
be epsilon close in l1 distance and
epsilon we can take to be one over poly
n so
much larger than the size of the output
object
random walks are a fundamental
algorithmic primitive so
starting from a fixed start vertex we
can generate a t-step random walk in
time roughly theta t just by doing the
walk
but what if we only want the position of
the walk at certain times
so we could have an algorithm that
desires data like what's the position of
the walk at time 300 okay v300
what's the position of time 10 000
v 10 000
what's the position at time 27
and so on and so forth
so we want the ability to answer queries
about the position of a random walk at
certain times and if we only need the
position of the walk at a small number
of times that could be much faster than
generating the entire walk in this case
of length 10 000 from the get go
and an important thing to note is that
fixing a random string r
um if a is a local computation algorithm
for random walks a will answer
consistent with a single random walk
fixing r
and what this means is
a's answer for the position of the walk
at time 300 has to depend on the
position of the walk at other times
because if you are answering totally
independently for each time step you
might say v300 is very far away from
v301
and that wouldn't be giving access to
the distribution of random walks
so we require this consistency between
times
which is an important aspect of our
algorithms
so one way to think about what we're
trying to do is we have this lcaa
sitting here and we give it access to a
random random tape
and we're going to receive a time query
so what's the position of the walk at
time t naught
and we're going to make some probes to
the graph learn about the graph and then
answer okay the walk is at position v
naught at that time
we're going to receive a second query
maybe we can answer that without doing
any more probes
and so on and so forth
so
our first set of results are in terms of
the expansion of a graph which is a
natural parameter to think about in the
context of random walks
first give a neighbor access to a
deregular undirected graph g with
spectral expansion lambda there's a
local access algorithm for walks on g
with per query work about 1 over 1 minus
lambda times root a
and so for expanders which have constant
spectral gap this is roughly root n work
perc query
second any algorithm that provides local
access to walks on random deregular
graphs requires roughly root n work
programmer
and since random deregular graphs are
expanders with high probability this is
in some sense a matching upper and lower
bound
our upper bound is based on the
observation that after a sufficient
number of times we can shatter the walk
into multiple different components
so
t mix is the mixing time of the graph
which is a parameter in terms of its
expansion and let's set k to be some
constant times the mixing time times log
n
and then for all integer multiples of k
so times zero time k time 2k etc let's
set the position of the walk at that
time to just be a uniformly random
vertex
so pick a number from one through n and
let that be the position at those times
so we've in some sense determined the
position of the walk at these at these
break points but we then want to
determine the position of the walk at
all intermediate time steps because for
instance we could get a query give us a
position at time t where t is between i
times k and i plus 1 times k
in order to do that we're going to
follow the following procedure
starting from the vertex that we've
determined v i k we're going to take a
random walk of length k over 2
and we're going to do the same thing
from the other end point
so we're going to continue taking these
random blocks all of length k over 2
and eventually
we're going to get a collision
there's going to be a walk of length k
over 2 from both of the endpoints that
have the final
that both have their endpoints the same
and all we're going to do is we're going
to declare that the first such collision
determines the walk between these
between these endpoints
so for these k steps the walk is
precisely the path taken by the first of
these colliding pairs
and the nice thing about this is that it
has a simple analysis in terms of time
and accuracy
so in order to compute the time required
to answer a query we can see that we
need to generate the start and end of
the walk which just involves selecting a
random vertex and then we need to
perform do the birthday paradox
something like root n times log n walks
with high probability all of length
roughly the mixing time from each
endpoint
and so in total in order to answer one
of these queries it takes us
1 over 1 minus lambda times root n up to
some polylog factors um and again for
expanders this is roughly root n work
perfect
so this is the this is the analysis of
time for the analysis of closeness we
can in some sense reorder the sequence
to
determine the position at zero determine
the position at k then k over two then
one through k minus one if we just
assume we're thinking about the first
block
and the reason for this is our procedure
is consistent wherever we query in the
middle of these time steps we're always
going to do the same thing of looking
for the first collision so we know we're
giving consistent answers
the position of the endpoint vertices
are just sampled uniformly at random and
we can show that this is close to the
true distribution because they're beyond
the mixing time from each other
the same thing happens when we look at
the distribution of the midpoint which
is distributed according to the location
of the first collision which is also
close to a uniformly random vertex which
itself is close to the true distribution
and finally if we look at the position
of the remaining determined vertices we
can see that these were sampled
according to a truly random block
conditioned on having the correct
endpoints
so
for all of the remaining positions we
sample these exactly according to the
correct distribution conditioned on v
naught v k over 2 and v k
so this concludes the analysis of the
upper bound
the lower bound is more complicated but
it's based on the following observation
since the algorithm does not know the
graph that it's generating walks on it
can only discover parts of this graph we
approach because recall we give it
access to a uniformly random deregular
graph and so we're going to exploit the
algorithm's lack of knowledge
what we do is we query the algorithm at
time 0 and time root n
and the algorithm returns v naught and v
root n
and so
since we constrain a in our lower bound
to spend much less than root n time
answering each query
the algorithm does not know of an actual
consistent random block from v naught to
v root n
it either knows one of two things first
um it doesn't know of any path between
the two vertices
or it knows of a path between the two
vertices but the path is much shorter
than the actual claimed time
and so in either case if we give a short
enough sequence of additional queries
the algorithm does not have enough time
to fix this and we can detect an
inconsistency
all of these lower bound results are
based on a main structural lemma which
states that given probe access to um a
random graph drawn from the distribution
of random deregular graphs any possibly
adaptive sequence of less than root n
neighbor probes will fail to find a
cycle with probability 0.99
um and the hidden constants here depend
on the degree d
and the proof of this uses the
configuration model of volaboss extended
by mccann world
so again to start our lower bound we
query at time zero and we query a time
root
and so the algorithm needs to commit to
the position of the walk at time zero
and time root n
now we can ask does the algorithm know a
path between these two vertices in terms
of the edges it's revealed through these
neighbor probes
if it doesn't we can binary search on
the component of the path that the
algorithm doesn't know
eventually we can force a to claim that
the walk traverses an edge that a does
not know actually exists in the graph
um and guessing an edge in a random
graph when you have been given few
probes fails with high probability
essentially via the main structural
lemma
if a does know a path the path known by
a after returning the second query must
be much too short to be a realistic
random walk
and so our new goal is to force a to
report some walk featuring an
implausible amount of backtracking
so what does this mean we can
formalize this by taking an algorithm's
eye view of the situation
so
what we're looking at right now is we're
saying that a is an algorithm which has
committed to the position of the walk at
time 0 and to time we're done and it
knows some edges in the graph so these
are the edges known to a
what we're going to do is we're going to
place a tree metric on the edges known
to the algorithm so we're going to
measure the distance between vertices um
using only the edges that a knows right
now
our bound on the number of probes we
allow the algorithm implies that the
tree metric distance between these two
vertices is much less than their claimed
time difference
and furthermore by the main structural
lemma a can't find cycles and so can't
find a second path from v naught to v
root
because if you find a
second path between these two vertices
you've managed to find a cycle which we
already said is impossible
with high probability
and so the algorithm can go and make
more queries and it can expand its its
tree of knowledge but it can never do
the thing that would break down our
analysis which is find a cycle
and if it does we simply terminate the
query sequence
so recall that we're assuming the
distance in terms of the tree metric
between these two vertices is much less
than their claimed time difference
what we're now going to do is we're
going to query at time t over two
so let's say the algorithm returns that
vt over two is here
in this case the return vertex is close
um within something times log n to the
path from v naught to v t
so there's one path from v naught to v t
in this tree and we can measure the
distance of v t over two to this path
and in this case it's equal to one
if v t over two is close
either the distance from v naught to v t
over two in this tree metric is much
less than the claim time difference or
the same happens for the second pair v2
over two and vt
and so in that case we can induct on a
part of the problem that we've in some
sense shrunk by a factor of two
but that's not the only thing the
algorithm can do
what it could also do
is take a reasonably long walk away from
this tree away from this existing tree
and report that vt over 2 is located
over here
in this case that means that v2 over 2
is far from this path from v naught to v
t
but in that case the algorithm has in
some sense committed to excessive
backtracking
eventually it's either going to have to
guess an edge or it's going to have to
report that the walk traverses down this
path
branches off takes a long trip to vt
over 2
does lots of backtracking and then
continues along this path
and eventually we'll force the algorithm
to report an inconsistency based on that
in the first case if we think of what
happens if the algorithm keeps reporting
close to the central path
eventually we'll get to a point where we
have vt and vt plus r which are
separated by um which have tree metric
distance much less than the claimed time
difference
and at the same time their claim time
difference is not too large it's some
constant times log n
in this case what we're going to do is
we're going to query at all time steps
between t and t plus r
after we've done that the algorithm in
some sense has two choices
first it can return a walk that leaves
the tree
but because i can't find cycles that
guarantees that the algorithm must have
guessed an edge in this random graph
which fails with high probability
otherwise the walk features implausibly
frequent backtracking because in some
sense a walk that's contained in this
tree has to spend most of its time going
back and forth between these edges um
and it doesn't visit
um it
has too much backtracking to be a
plausible random walk which we can
detect
in the second case
if we have some reported vertex that's
more than
something log n steps away from this
central path
we can either again force an algorithm
to guess an edge or commit to revisiting
some vertex in the walk after something
like
80 log n steps
and one can show that revisiting a
vertex in a walk on a random regular
graph after greater than that number of
steps is um highly unlikely
and in both of these cases we use
variants of the main structure lemma to
establish properties of random walks on
random irregular graphs and then show
that the algorithm is unable to emulate
this behavior
so in summary if the algorithm took
fewer than root n divided by some
constant depending on d steps to answer
the second query after log n additional
queries we can force it to return an
event that occurs with vanishing
probability in a truly random walk
and so that constitutes our lower back
so one way to characterize the problem
is in terms of the expansion of the
graph but there are other ways of
characterizing
graphs that we might want to provide
local access to and in fact if we
instead impose some algebraic structure
we can do much better
so for instance for g and a
billion-calorie graph of degree d
there's a local access algorithm for
walks on this graph with time per query
pauli d
times log n
and so what this allows us to get is
efficient local access to walks on some
popular graphs like the cycle the
hypercube and even order login degree
expanders
finally there are several open problems
related to this line of research
the most general and also the most
interesting i believe is local access to
more random objects
both efficient local access to more
types of structured graphs
and more generally other types of large
random objects
as an addendum to this
prior works have given non-memoryless
local access algorithms so algorithms in
which a does not have its memory erased
after receiving a query and so the
random object is allowed to in some
sense remember its prior decisions
and it would be interesting to see which
of those results can be converted into
the memoryless setting
thank you